[Musique]
alors que comporte de la loi elle
comporte d'abord par un nouvel article
314 du code pénal
la répression de deux choses l'action
menée par un groupe c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'action de commandos du fait
d'une d'un rassemblement interdit ou
illicites sont commis des violences
what fait est bien
les chefs et organisateur seront unis de
six mois à trois ans de prison et je
pense j'espère que sa véritable
efficacité sera une efficacité de
dissuasion
car quand pour paraphraser le mot du
premier ministre les casseurs auront
compris qu'ils risquaient d'être le
payeur il résume nous lançons à être les
casseurs c'est le bien que je le reçois
[Musique]
la loi dite loi anti casseurs ou plus
exactement
soyons précis le projet de loi tendant à
réprimer certaines formes nouvelles de
délinquance suscite des remous au
parlement et dans l'opinion publique
[Musique]
nous on doit notre code pénal permettent
de répondre à cette question
en vérité le gouvernement a saisi
l'occasion comme s'ils avaient voulu
profiter des circonstances pour élargir
incroyablement le la délinquance
possible c'est ainsi que en fait il
interdit désormais le droit de
manifester le droit de se réunir en
vérité le gouvernement fait une droite
police
[Musique]